Let's go back to the phones at (617) 830-4750
where many times
people are a hoping to get on. Let's go to
our caller from the eight six Oh area code
color from eight six so maybe down in Connecticut,
is that possible? Eight six. So maybe you
have this muted, but I can't hear you. Eight
six. So going once eight six. So going twice.
No, eight six so, all right, that's too bad.
Let's try instead. Three four seven. Who's
calling today from the three four seven area
code.
Hello?
Yes, that's you.
Hey David, I'm a big fan of your show. Thank
you. I have a, I have a question. Do you,
which democratic ticket do you think would
be best? Which candidates, president and vice
president do you think would win a best? Cause?
I know there are a lot of mixes and matches
that would be Trump, but I know there are
a lot that aren't. There are a lot that wouldn't.
What is your opinion?
I have not thought about vice-presidential
at all. So I really couldn't tell you. I mean
w w as far as what the polling says right
now in terms of who could beat Trump in the
general, you know, both Bernie and Biden do
really well against Trump and hypothetical
polls. Harrison Warren do well, but not quite
as well. I'm just sort of going from memory
here. But as far as VP, I mean, listen, in
one sense, I don't think VP is going to matter
that much in 2020. I think that this thing
is going to be won or lost on a couple of
things. One turnout in a few key states who
gets slightly more people to vote. Number
two, how much voter suppression takes place,
and number three, how well the eventual Democratic
nominee is going to be able to fight back
against Trump's personal attacks and his style
during the debates. The VP candidate is ultimately
only going to debate Mike Pence or whoever
replaces Mike pence on the ticket. If he's
replaced, that's not gonna matter nearly as
much as, uh, the, the other things that I
mentioned. So I honestly, I have not thought
about VP at all.
Hmm. That's interesting. I, I believe that
since there are a lot of popular Democratic
candidates that, uh, that are, could be popular
in one area but really, really unpopular in
another area. I know, uh, I know that we have
a lot of, I know I will very much like Andrew
Yang. Um, well actually, no, he might not
be the best example, but there are a lot of
coastal Democratic candidates that don't think
could do well in the south. Um, and there
are a lot of candidates say, uh, Biden were,
or, you know, actually say Warren or say maybe
even, uh, well I guess if we're not going
to count the straight white candidates that
the won't really make the second round of
debates, but I don't think people like Warren
could really, uh, make the, uh, make, uh,
people in the Midwest or even on the west
coast. Uh, very,
I know, I, I generally think that you're right,
you are correct that different candidates
will appeal to different pieces of the electorate
to different degrees. I actually think you're
wrong about Warren Warren does really well
when she goes to the Midwest and talks to
Trump voters and explains policy. I actually
think that she will do better than people
give her credit for. Although I completely
agree with what you're saying, that the idea
of northeastern liberals in the deep south
for example, it, it, there may be some lack
of appeal there, but I actually think Warren
does really well when she talks to red state
voters.
I might look into that. That's very interesting.
Thank you for, uh, for talking with me.
I appreciate it. Yeah, thank you for the call.
Great to hear from you.